This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。绝对真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，如何建立心理韧性、保持健康并培养抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是数字 2. percent，可在 iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听《回看过去》播客。从1979年开始，对我来说那是意义重大的一年。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
欢迎在 iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯主持的《知难而进》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着重重的盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就非得这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
请在 iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的平台上收听《知难而进》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在 iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《深陷爱河》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》，这是一档探讨我们二十岁时经历的重大生活变化与过渡及其含义的播客。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here as we of course break down, dive into the psychology of your 20s. Something that I think comes up a lot when we think about love, crushes, dating, romance is this like behavioral concept, this behavioral idea of learning. And it feels kind of strange to be doing an entire episode on flirting because I don't know, I feel like I'm in this long-term relationship. Like, I don't really think about it as much anymore. But when you are single, or even when you are in a long-term relationship and you want to kind of bring a little bit of passion back into things, flirting is super valuable. And it's also this idea that
谈谈它们对我们心理的影响。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴有你们陪伴，当然，我们要剖析和深入探讨二十岁心理学。我觉得当我们想到爱情、迷恋、约会和浪漫时，经常会出现这样一个行为概念，即关于学习的行为理念。感觉做一整期关于调情的节目有点奇怪，因为我不知道，我觉得自己正处于一一段长期关系中。所以，我不再怎么去想它了。但是当你单身时，或者甚至当你处于长期关系中，想要为生活重新注入一点激情时，调情是非常宝贵的。这也是这样一个理念：
is closely aligned with confidence, romantic confidence, with attraction. I feel like flirting is honestly just so much fun. You don't know where it's going to take you. It can bring you so much power and self-esteem. It puts you kind of in the driver's seat of a relationship. But it's not always so easy to do. And not all of us are quite the expert. So today I thought I would bring someone on to discuss the unique psychology of flirting. And I thought I would bring on the literal expert, a flirting coach, Benjamin Kamras. Thank you so much for joining us. Hello, thank you so much for having me on the show today. I am thrilled and delighted to talk about my favorite thing in the world, which is flirting. I'm actually so excited as well.
它与自信、浪漫的自信以及吸引力紧密相连。我觉得调情老实说真的太有趣了。你永远不知道它会把你带向何方。它能给你带来巨大的力量和自尊。它让你在一段关系中处于掌控地位。但这并不总是那么容易做到。而且我们并非所有人都是行家里手。所以今天我想请一位嘉宾来探讨调情的独特心理学。我想请来的正是绝对的专家、调情教练本杰明·卡姆拉斯。非常感谢你加入我们。你好，非常感谢今天邀请我上节目。我感到非常兴奋和高兴能谈论我世上最喜欢的事物，那就是调情。其实我也非常兴奋。
I was like, this is just perfect because it is such like a, I don't know, it's like something that people don't think about all that often, but then when you kind of have it down pat, I'm sure it opens so many doors. Before we jump into it, can you just like briefly introduce yourself what you do, who you are, any fun facts that you want to include? Yes, my name is Benjamin. I am the floor coach and Gay Libra self-proclaimed. And I got into this a couple of years ago. I had a whole nine to five before I got myself or found myself discovering coaching. I was a city planner for a long, long time for over 10 years. That's what I went to school for more formally. And then when I was exploring a career change, as I think a lot of us were contemplating many things during lockdown. and during the pandemic, having a lot of time to ourselves, I was living by myself and had all of this time just to like actually be instead of doing, right, going, just forcing myself to always be busy. That really wasn't an option. And I knew I had to make some serious life changes, some big upheavals.
我想说，这简直太完美了，因为这就像是那种，我不知道，人们不会经常去想的事情，但一旦你掌握了窍门，我相信它会为你打开无数扇大门。在我们深入探讨之前，你能简要介绍一下你自己、你是做什么的、你的身份，以及任何你想分享的有趣事实吗？好的，我叫本杰明。我自封是一位调情教练和骄傲的天秤座。我几年前开始接触这个领域。在发现教练这一行并投身其中之前，我有一份朝九晚五的正式工作。我曾做过很长一段时间的城市规划师，超过10年了。那是我正儿八经上学所学的专业。然后，当我在探索职业转型时，我想我们很多人在封控期间都在认真考虑各种事情，
And a conversation with a friend changed everything. I was just talking to him, like I, what am I going to do? Like I, what do I do with my life? I was in my mid-30s then. I'm 38 now. And he was like, what about coaching? What, just what about coaching? I had no idea what that was.
在大流行期间，我们有很多时间独处，我一个人住，有所有这些时间来真正地“存在”而不是“做事”，对吧？去行动，强迫自己总是保持忙碌。那真的不是一个选项。我知道我必须做出一些重大的生活改变，进行一些大的颠覆。
I had never considered that before. I had like these ideas in my head if you've seen movies or TV shows with life coaches. Yeah. They kind of get played up as a stereotype or like the football coach, something like that. But me as a coach, I don't know. But for the first time in a. really long time. He recommended a program to me. And within the week, I was signed up and enrolled. And I explored coaching before I quit my job and then started my business and was posting
而与一位朋友的交谈改变了一切。我当时只是在和他聊天，比如我该怎么办？我的人生该何去何从？我当时三十岁出头。我现在38岁了。他说，当教练怎么样？什么，当教练怎么样？我当时完全不知道那是什么。
online, trying all kinds of different things. And the video that really changed everything was a video about flirting. And that's when the stars aligned, everything clicked. And I have not turned back since. And that was about a year and a half ago when I really started creating content and talking about flirting and becoming evolving into the flirt coach, which is how I show up today. Oh my gosh. I love it. And I will say, like, you bring such like this like, it's beautiful energy to this recording where I'm like, yeah, I get why you're an expert in this. And it's so, it's so funny you being like, oh, the idea of like a coach. And I always think of like hitch, like the, What's the actor in that? Will Smith?
我以前从未考虑过这一点。如果你看过电影或电视剧里关于生活教练的桥段，我脑海里就有这样的印象。对。他们有点被刻板化了，或者像橄榄球教练之类的。但至于我成为一名教练，我不知道。不过这是很长一段时间以来的第一次。他向我推荐了一个项目。不到一周的时间，我就报名注册了。我在辞职前探索了教练的工作，然后开始创业，在网上发帖，
Will Smith, yeah. But you're very, very different, which I appreciate. Thanks for giving us that little timeline. Okay, I'm going to start such a simple question. When I started, I was like, I thought this would be a great introduction question. I was like, this is such a simple question. And then I started thinking about it myself. And I was like, actually, this is quite complicated.
尝试各种不同的事情。真正改变一切的那段视频是一个关于调情的视频。就在那时，群星归位，一切都豁然开朗。从那以后，我再也没有回头。那大约是一年半前，我真正开始创作内容、谈论调情，并演变成今天的调情教练。天哪。我太喜欢了。而且我得说，你带来了这种，这种美丽的能量到这个录音中，让我觉得，是的，我明白为什么你是这方面的专家了。而且你觉得“哦，教练的概念”这事儿真逗，我总是想起像《全民情敌》里那样的角色，那个演员是谁？威尔·史密斯？
So to begin, what actually kind of defines or qualifies as flow? flooding. Yeah, so I have a definition that I think is unconventional that maybe you all haven't heard before, but my just like concise definition of flirting is that the flirt is the genuine expression of interest without expectation in the present moment. And I talk about the flirt as being all about connection. For me, that's the sole purpose of the flirt. It doesn't come in with these angles or these intentions, right? You're just trying to get the phone number or you're coming right away with a physical compliment, something like that. I really try and always bring it back to connection. As I see, that's been a huge part of my work, even as a city planner, where I was working
威尔·史密斯，对。但你非常非常不同，我很欣赏这一点。谢谢你为我们梳理这个简短的时间线。好的，我要从一个非常简单的问题开始。刚开始时，我想，这会是一个很好的开场问题。我想，这是一个非常简单的问题。然后我自己开始思考。然后我想，其实这相当复杂。
in transportation and connectivity and sidewalks and things like that. Connection in a different way. And I'm still continuing with that theme now as the flirt coach, just hoping and hoping to bring more connection into people's lives. I hope to inspire them to, yeah, just to express themselves, to put themselves out there, to build confidence. Yeah, that's what I hope every time I post and talk about flirting. So that's my like sort of a clean, clear definition of flirting, but it is ultimately always, always, always. about connection. Yeah, I like that. So this kind of leads to my next question. Does it always have to indicate like romantic or even sexual interest or is it like just kind of, can it be playful, platonic? Yes. Yes. So when it comes to connection, I think you have
那么首先，到底什么才算是调情呢？调情。是的，我有一个自认为不同寻常的定义，也许你们以前没听过，但我对调情简洁的定义是：调情是在当下不抱任何期望地真诚表达兴趣。我谈论的调情完全关乎连接。对我来说，那是调情的唯一目的。它不是带着某种目的或意图而来的，对吧？你不是一上来就为了要电话号码，或者一上来就给出一个身体上的赞美之类的那种。我真的总是试着把它拉回到连接上。正如我所看到的，这是我工作中的一个巨大部分，甚至在我担任城市规划师时也是如此，当时我从事
three varieties of connection, platonic connections, romantic connections and the connection you have with yourself and you're going to explore all of them in the flirt. It's, I know, like, sometimes I feel like I don't have, like, the juiciest, like, ripest answer of the flirt is, like, this sort of salacious, like, overt expression of sexual or romantic interest. It can be. There's a time and a place for that. Certainly if you're in a relationship and, like, you're, yeah, the flirt can help keep some of that aspect of a relationship alive. And even when you're dating, flirting in the bedroom,
交通、连通性、人行道之类的工作。以一种不同的方式建立连接。现在作为调情教练，我仍在延续这个主题，只是希望并将更多连接带入人们的生活。我希望能激励他们，是的，去表达自我，去展现自己，去建立自信。是的，这就是我每次发帖和谈论调情时的期望。所以这就是我对调情的一个干净、清晰的定义，但它归根结底，永远、永远、永远都是关于连接。是的，我喜欢这样。所以这自然引出了我的下一个问题。它必须总是暗示浪漫甚至性趣吗？还是说，它可以很俏皮、柏拉图式？是的。
something like that, love it. But when you're on a first date, you're with someone you don't know or you see someone at a party at a party, a networking event, outrunning errands. You don't even know their name. That can never be where you start. It has to start first with connection. So I the flirt has many varieties and many forms, but it's ultimately about exploring those connections platonically, romantically, and with the self. And yeah, depending on the actual connection, then it can take many different forms. I'm so interested in this. Like how do you flirt with yourself? Like what's, what does that entail? Oh, so it's like how you are showing up to the flirt. Like it's because I am part of the form.
是的。所以当谈到连接时，我认为你有三种连接，柏拉图式的连接、浪漫的连接，以及你与自己的连接，你将在调情中探索所有这些。我知道，有时候我觉得我没有关于调情的最诱人、最成熟的答案，比如那种猥亵的、对性或浪漫兴趣的直接表达。当然可以有。那有其时间和地点。当然，如果你在恋爱中，并且，是的，调情可以帮助保持恋爱关系中的某些方面充满活力。甚至当你约会时，在卧室里调情，
Part of my story is a lifelong introvert. I still am introverted in many ways. I've had social anxiety my entire life. So just making connections, let alone flirting, hasn't been easy. But so much about the flirt is how you show up and what's going on in your mind. Are you judging yourself? Are you being critical of yourself? Are you rejecting yourself?
诸如此类，我喜欢。但当你第一次约会时，你和不认识的人在一起，或者你在派对上、社交活动中、出门办事时看到某人。你甚至不知道他们的名字。那绝不可能是你开始的地方。它必须首先从连接开始。所以我有许多种类和形式的调情，但它归根结底是关于以柏拉图式、浪漫以及与自我的方式去探索这些连接。是的，根据实际的连接，它可以采取许多不同的形式。我对这个非常感兴趣。比如你如何对自己调情？这包含什么？哦，这就像你如何展现自己来参与调情。因为我是形式的一部分。
Are you bringing past stories and experiences into the flirt? So the connection with the self as it's related to flirting is about how you are showing up because you are a critical part of the flirt. Okay, I kind of get that now. I'm like, okay, so the relationship, like how you kind of flirt with yourself is by, I'm guessing, like, flirting with others, but by doing that, it brings a sense of confidence and it brings a sense of empowerment that maybe you previously don't have. Like, I'm showing up to this experience. I'm going to just give it a go. I'm going to just put myself out there. And like a previous version of myself may have been worried about rejection, but this version of myself that I want to create is not someone who does. Is that kind of what it's like? Yeah, it can very much be that.
我故事的一部分是一个内向的人。在很多方面我仍然很内向。我一生都有社交焦虑。所以仅仅是建立连接，更不用说调情了，并不容易。但调情的很大一部分在于你如何展现自己以及你的脑海里在想什么。你在评判自己吗？你在对自我进行批判吗？你在拒绝自己吗？
And I think like for everyone listening is like some other ways to flirt with yourself are, right, to wear something that really makes you feel good, a favorite color. You're playing with your style, your makeup, your hair could be like it could be. It could be. flirting with your with your positive self talk self-talk or your affirmations you could even take it in the direction of like you're flirting with new habits yeah flirting with a new i don't know cooking class or something like that yeah um so there's lots of ways to then open up the flirt and think of it yeah bring it into kind of all aspects of your life but it's i love it as a tool for self-discovery and just to help people get to know themselves better and so when you're showing up to the flirt
你把过去的故事和经历带进调情中了吗？所以，与自我的连接，当它与调情相关时，关乎你如何展现自己，因为你是调情中至关重要的一部分。好吧，我有点明白了。我想，好吧，那么这种关系，比如你如何对自己调情，我猜，是通过与他人调情，但通过这样做，它带来了一种自信和赋权感，而这可能是你以前所没有的。比如，我以这样的状态面对这段经历。我要去尝试一下。我要勇敢地展现自我。我以前的那个版本可能会担心被拒绝，但我想要打造的这个版本不是一个会这样的人。是那种感觉吗？是的，非常可能是那样。
It's like, what are those thoughts? It's like, is it I'm too weird or I'm too awkward or I'm not like, I don't look good enough? Or like, what is it that's happening? Or maybe you're feeling super, super good. You're like, I got this. Yeah. You have like your opening line or your pickup line or something like that. So it's ultimately, I think, a great way to build self-awareness around how you like to connect.
我想对于所有听众来说，其他对自己调情的方式还有，穿上一件真正让你感觉良好的衣服，你最喜欢的颜色。你玩转自己的风格、妆容、发型，这可以。这可以。用积极的自我对话或肯定语来调情。你甚至可以朝着这样的方向发展：用新习惯调情，是的，用一堂新烹饪课或类似的东西调情。是的，所以有很多方法可以开启调情并思考它，是的，把它带入你生活的方方面面。但我非常喜欢它作为自我发现的工具，只是为了帮助人们更好地了解自己。所以当你展现自己参与调情时，
And with that self-awareness, you can. You know, then you can take action on sort of what's happening, what's coming up, what thoughts are you having and why. So I feel like some people are definitely more flotatious than others. Do you think that like that comes down to personality or does it just come down to sheer confidence, like a sheer willingness or not even willingness, just an ability to, you know, potentially be rejected or to be, feel embarrassed or whatever it is? Like, do you think it's personality? Do you think it's confidence? What really makes some people more tapped into the flirt, as you call it? Yeah, that's a good question. I think everyone has an inner flirt. And when it comes to, yeah, you see people that seem like they just have this natural flirt confidence about them. I think sometimes it could be more innate, you know, if it's
这些想法是什么？是“我太奇怪了”、“我太尴尬了”还是“我不够好”、“我不够有吸引力”？或者到底发生了什么？或者也许你感觉超级超级好。你心想：“我能行。”是的。你有你的开场白或搭讪语之类的东西。所以归根结底，我认为这是围绕你喜欢如何建立连接来建立自我意识的好方法。
someone that is more extroverted, if it's someone that is totally cool and love. receiving attention because that's part of the flirt too as you're giving attention energy to someone else sharing that but then looking to receive it back so some people love they love giving a compliment because they know they're going to get some attention back that could be part of it some people have you know humor that just lends itself more to that kind of in the moment right they're not so much in their heads but I think what truly makes a natural flirt, a sort of quote unquote natural flirt is not how they look or anything like that, it's their ability to just get out of their head with the flirt and not second guess themselves
有了这种自我意识，你可以。你知道的，然后你可以对正在发生的事情、浮现的事情、你有什么想法以及为什么会有这些想法采取行动。我觉得有些人绝对比其他人更擅长调情。你认为这归结于性格，还是仅仅归结于纯粹的自信、纯粹的意愿，甚至都不是意愿，而只是一种能力，去（潜在地）面对被拒绝、感到尴尬或无论什么？你认为这是性格吗？你认为这是自信吗？是什么真正让某些人更能融入你所说的调情状态？是的，这是一个好问题。我认为每个人内心都有一个调情高手。当谈到，是的，你会看到那些看起来天生就自带这种调情自信的人。我想有时这可能更具天生性，你知道，如果
in the moment. It really does a lot of times come down to confidence. And how do you do that? Like if you're someone who wants the opportunities brought on by flirting, like the playfulness, like maybe more connection or like the ability to kind of express romantic interests and have that like reciprocated. What are someone like the strategies that maybe you've used or you've seen other people used to get themselves out of their heads into the present, into the situation? Yeah. That's my that's my motto at the open of all of all my podcast episodes to get out of your
这个人更加外向，如果这个人完全酷并且热爱。接受关注，因为这也是调情的一部分，当你向别人给予关注和能量、分享这些，但又期待收回时。所以有些人喜欢，他们喜欢给予赞美，因为他们知道自己会得到一些关注作为回报，这可能是其中的一部分。有些人拥有，你知道，更适合那种当下情境的幽默感，对吧？他们不会想太多，但我认为真正让一个天生调情高手脱颖而出的，或者说所谓的“天生调情高手”，不是他们的外表或类似的东西，而是他们能够跳出自己的思维框架去调情、不自我怀疑的能力。
head and enter the flirt to stop thinking your way through the flirt more so feel your way through the flirt. And I think one way you do that is by opening up your experience of flirting and your idea of what flirting is, your concept of what flirting is, and look to make those connections with everyone regardless of whether or not you think they're hot, right? You want someone to give you attention back. You see someone that has piqued your interest that now you want to go on a date with or you want to hook up with whatever. If you're going into the flirt with this very narrow-minded point of view of who you think this person is and you're already assuming the role that you that you want them to play in your life because of how they look, let's just say, well, it's just, the flirt may
在当下。很多时候它确实归结于自信。你该怎么做呢？如果你是一个想要通过调情带来机会的人，比如趣味性、也许更多的连接，或者表达浪漫兴趣并得到回应的能力。你用过或见过其他人用过什么策略来让自己摆脱胡思乱想，进入当下，进入这种情境？是的。这是我所有播客节目开场时的座右铭：跳出你的思维，
not be received that way, first of all, but then also you're very much limiting yourself to the types of flirts you can experience and to the types of people that you're going to flirt and then connect with. So I love just opening up people's idea of what the flirt is, the role it can serve in their lives, being that it's ultimately all about connection. It's playful. It's an energetic exchange. Sometimes I describe it as an act of service. It really is that. It's an opportunity for you to learn some incredible things about someone else, about yourself. And so if. If you're struggling with confidence or you just feel like you don't have the confidence to do that, think about the times in your life when you have made connections, just in the moment, could be with friends. And maybe you don't consider that a flirt, but connection is connection nonetheless.
进入调情状态，停止在调情中过度思考，而是用感觉去体会调情。我认为你可以通过拓宽你的调情体验、你对调情的看法以及你对调情的概念来做到这一点，并试着与每个人建立这些连接，而不管你是否认为他们很火辣，对吧？你希望别人给你回应。你看到一个激起你兴趣的人，现在你想和他约会或者你想和他有一段关系。如果你带着这种对这个人的狭隘观点进入调情，并且因为他们的外表，比方说，你已经在心里假定你想让他们在你的生活中扮演什么角色，那么首先，这种调情可能
And so you've proven to yourself that you can do it. I really like that. Like, lower firstly lowering your expectation, not even lowering, but changing your expectations around what flirting actually is. the desired outcome, like going into it, being like, okay, well, this is more about me than it is about them as of right now. Like, this is a confidence building thing for me. I'm just going to try and do it. And then the outcome is whatever it is. Whatever it is. Like, it's a learning process. I want to talk about some more like practical ways to flirt. Okay. Okay. So, and maybe this is like very, I want it to be very specifically. What do you think of the most effective ways of flirting,
不会被那样接受，而且你也将自己能体验到的调情类型以及你将要调情并连接的人的类型大大局限了。所以我非常喜欢拓宽人们对调情的看法，它在生活中可以发挥的作用，因为归根结底它完全关乎连接。它是好玩的。它是一种能量的交换。有时我把它描述为一种服务行为。它确实如此。这是一个让你了解关于别人、关于你自己的不可思议的事情的机会。所以如果。如果你在与自信作斗争，或者你觉得自己没有自信去做到这一点，想想你生活中曾经建立连接的那些时刻，哪怕只是在当下，也可以和朋友一起。也许你并不认为那是调情，但连接就是连接。
whether it's like asking questions, like physical, what in your mind and your experience really works? So I love starting with flirt styles, I think, can be super useful. This is something that came from the University of Kansas. There's published research on this. Like, there's actually been four or five, but I've really distilled them down into four flirt styles, where there's playful, sincere, traditional, and physical. And I think I would even add a fifth now, most recently, the demure flirt. If you're on social media, you have probably seen that trend. So I think knowing your flirt style can be super, super helpful.
所以你已经向自己证明了你能做到这一点。我真的很喜欢这样。首先降低你的期望，甚至不是降低，而是改变你对调情实际是什么的期望。期望达到的结果，比如带着这样的心态进入：“好吧，这更多是关于我，而不是关于他们，就目前而言。”比如，这对我是个建立自信的事情。我要去尝试一下。然后结果顺其自然。顺其自然。比如，这是一个学习的过程。我想谈谈更多关于实际的调情方法。好的。好的。所以，也许这非常，我希望它非常具体。你认为最有效的调情方式是什么，
And then it comes back to working the flirt nonverbaly and verbally. So ultimately, with flirt styles, it's how. How do you like to express interest in somebody? How you like to connect. Do you like I'm very much a playful flirt. I have elements of sincere. We have elements of all of them, but you probably have one or two that are more dominant. So I'm very playful.
无论是问问题，还是肢体语言，在你看来，在你的经验中，什么真正起作用？我喜欢从调情风格开始，我认为这非常有用。这是源自堪萨斯大学的东西。对此有已发表的研究。比如，实际上有四五种，但我把它们真正提炼成了四种调情风格，即俏皮型、真诚型、传统型和身体接触型。我想我最近甚至会加上第五种，羞怯（demure）型。如果你在社交媒体上，你可能见过那个潮流。所以我觉得了解自己的调情风格会非常非常有帮助。
I use lots of body language, hand motions. I'm very expressive with my eyes and my face. I play with my tone of voice. So I bring a lot of playful elements. I bring some humor into it. And then I pair that with sincerity where I, I'm asking genuine questions. I'm practicing active listening.
然后这就回归到通过非语言和语言来运用调情。归根结底，调情风格关乎如何。你喜欢如何向某人表达兴趣？你喜欢如何连接。你喜欢——我非常属于俏皮型调情。我有真诚型的元素，我们都有所有这些元素的成分，但你可能会有一到两种更为主导的风格。所以我非常俏皮。
I'm offering compliments that are non-physical. Yeah. Can you break down those four flirt styles by profile? Because I feel like I get those examples. I was like, yeah, I kind of can think of some examples of sincere and of playful and of physical. But what are some of the more detailed, like criteria or kind of characteristics of each of those styles? Yeah. So playful is the type of flirt that is going to lean.
我使用大量的肢体语言、手势。我的眼神和面部表情非常丰富。我玩转我的声调。所以我带来了很多俏皮的元素。我给它带来了一些幽默感。然后我将其与真诚结合起来，我提出真诚的问题。我练习积极倾听。
more towards humor. You might even like roast someone a little bit if this is someone you know kind of well. You're going to be very just overall playful and expressive probably in your demeanor. Since the sincere flirt really likes to ask questions and offer compliments. Like this is the person that is like maybe they don't bring a ton of humor or jokes to the flirt. but they are like they're in it, they're asking those questions so they can really get to know you
我提供非身体接触的赞美。是的。你能按档案细分这四种调情风格吗？因为我觉得我明白了那些例子。我想，是的，我能想到真诚型、俏皮型和身体接触型的一些例子。但这些风格中更详细的标准或特征是什么？好的。所以俏皮型是那种倾向于幽默的调情类型。
and understand you better. The traditional flirt is, this style of flirt is like it's sort of like quote unquote playing it safe a little bit, but that's not how I want to describe it. Like they really follow a lot of traditional conventions when it comes to getting to know someone.
如果你和这个人相当熟的话，你甚至可能会稍微开开玩笑逗逗对方。你的举止可能会非常俏皮且富有表现力。真诚型的调情者真正喜欢问问题并提供赞美。比如这类人可能不会在调情中带来大量的幽默或笑话。但他们全身心投入，他们会问那些问题，以便真正了解你
So kind of like, hello, how are you? My name is. Like they're not really going to be, touchy-feely or looking to give a hug or something like that, they're sort of going to, we really respect a lot of boundaries in a sense right of way and it can give the illusion of a slower burn style of flirt, but this is just how this person likes to express interest. This is so interesting. Can I interact with? Of course. That is so interesting because that sounds like spot on like my partner. Like when we first started
并更好地理解你。传统型调情，这种调情风格有点像“稳妥起见”，但这并不是我想描述的方式。比如他们在了解某人时确实遵循了很多传统规范。
dating, I was like, are you even into me? But he would do things like. like, oh, open the door for me. Buy me flowers. But then I would be like, you know, then I remember like on maybe our third day, he like gave me a hug and it was like the most awkward hug I've ever had. Because he's just like not what he was used to. And he's like, but he is definitely like, it's so funny listening to this thing. Like, oh yeah, he's totally traditional and very much like sincere where he will be like
所以有点像，你好，你好吗？我的名字是。比如他们不会真正地、动手动脚的或者想要一个拥抱之类的，他们会在某种程度上真正尊重很多界限，这可能会给人一种慢热型调情风格的错觉，但这只是这个人喜欢表达兴趣的方式。这太有趣了。我可以互动吗？当然。这太有趣了，因为这听起来完全像我的伴侣。当我们刚开始
doing all the things that you would expect from like a gentleman in like the 1930s. Yeah. So I think that's probably his flirt style, traditional, with elements of sincere. Yeah, which is interesting. Sorry, I interrupted. And the last one is... Oh, the last one is physical. And this one, like, our minds tend to go right to, oh, this is the person that is, like, giving physical compliments right away.
约会时，我想：他对我有感觉吗？但他会做一些事情，比如。比如，为我开门。给我买花。然后我会想，然后我记得也许在我们第三次约定时，他给了我一个拥抱，那是我经历过最尴尬的拥抱。因为他只是不习惯那样。他就像，但他绝对是，听这个觉得太逗了：“哦，对，他完全是传统的，而且非常真诚，他会做所有你对1930年代绅士所期望的事情。”是的。所以我想这可能是他的调情风格，传统的，带有一点真诚的元素。是的，这很有趣。抱歉，我打断了。最后一个是……哦，最后一个是身体接触型。这种类型，我们的思维往往会直接联想到，哦，这就是那种立刻给予身体接触赞美的人。
They're being very touchy-feely. To an extent, yes, like, when this is someone you get to know, but right away in an initial flirt, this is someone that I feel like brings just a lot of physical energy. They're very animated, like with their body language, they're going to be very open. I think a little bit more relaxed. They may do a little bit of, like, touching you on top of the shoulder, sort of nudging their shoulder into yours. Like, they're going to gravitate towards some touch probably as a means to express interest. But that can be conveyed in a one-dimensional way, even though if it's not meaning to be intended as like, hey, I want you kind of thing. Yeah, and then the demure flirt, which is this new one that you've...
他们非常喜欢动手动脚。在某种程度上，是的，当这是一个你了解的人时，但在最初的调情中，这感觉就像是一个带来大量身体活力的人。他们非常生动，比如他们的肢体语言，会非常开放。我认为稍微更放松一些。他们可能会做一点，比如拍拍你的肩膀，或者把肩膀蹭到你的肩膀上。比如他们可能会倾向于通过某种接触来表达兴趣。但这可以用一种单一维度的方式传达，即使它并不意味着“嘿，我想要你”那种意图。是的，还有羞怯型，这是你最近引入的新类型……
Yeah. Is it something you've just recently introduced based on like the trend? Yes, exactly that. I think it would be a very fun, fifth flirt style where this is the flirt that's very mindful, right? Very respectable, very approachable. I'm kind of getting like, you know, the flirt that's like a little bit more laid back sort of come to me kind of thing. But I see them as also bringing a lot of sincere and playful elements. too. So maybe the demure is a combination of playful and sincere. Yeah. It's so interesting,
是的。这是你根据潮流最近才引入的吗？是的，完全如此。我认为这将是一个非常有趣的第五种调情风格，这种调情非常正派，对吧？非常受人尊敬，非常平易近人。我有点觉得，你知道，那种稍微悠闲一点、有点“来找我吧”之类的调情。但我认为他们也带来了很多真诚和俏皮的元素。所以也许羞怯型是俏皮和真诚的结合。是的。这太有趣了，
like hearing you say these and being like they, a lot of them kind of align with like our love languages, right? Like, you know, acts of service being traditional, like words of affirmation being sincere, physical touch being physical, which is very, and I feel like, and that's what you were explaining before where it's like there is no way to go about like showing interest in someone. It does sometimes need. to be a combination, but you start small. It's like asking a question. I feel like the thing that really holds people back from outwardly flirting is being embarrassed
听到你这么说，觉得它们在很大程度上与我们的爱的语言相吻合，对吧？比如，服务行动就是传统的，肯定的话语就是真诚的，身体接触就是身体的，这非常，我觉得，这就是你之前解释的，表达对某人的兴趣没有固定不变的方式。有时它确实需要。是一种组合，但你要从小事做起。就像问一个问题。我觉得真正阻止人们公开调情的是因为尴尬
about being called out by it for it. It's like, yes, rejection is a component. It's like someone just not reciprocating, but it's also like, okay, someone has noticed that I'm doing it and is then turned off by that. But what you were saying of like, it can be so small, like just asking a really sincere your question is a way of like embracing the flirt or like being like very demure and very much like, oh, I want you to come and come and chase B in a way. Also another great example. So do you think that it's better to be like more subtle or more obvious when it comes to
而害怕被人当场指出。是的，拒绝是一个组成部分。就像某人只是没有回应，但这也是，好吧，有人注意到我在这么做，然后对此感到反感。但你刚才说的，它可以很小，比如问一个非常真诚的问题，就是一种拥抱调情的方式，或者表现得非常羞怯，非常像是“哦，我希望你过来追求我”。这也是一个很好的例子。那么你认为在调情时，表现得更含蓄还是更明显会更好？我认为这取决于情况。这可能，这种调情的风格可以更遵循。
flirting? I think it depends. Like it could, like the flirt in that way could follow more. or normative gender roles if it's like, well, the guy's going to approach the woman kind of thing. And so like the woman is then giving some of those signals with some body language, some eye contact, right, pulling the eye contact away. Maybe like the hair gets tucked behind the ear and like sort of like, like I don't know, tongue, I don't know, bite the bottom lip or something like some of these sort of traditional expressions of nonverbal interest we may think of. But it's like from what I hear and in doing the work that I do, it's like, I think everyone can approach everybody. But it starts with the point of connection and then letting it build from there.
规范的性别角色，如果是那种“男生会去追求女生”之类的。所以女生就会通过一些肢体语言、一些眼神接触、把眼神移开来发出这些信号。比如头发别在耳后，然后，我不知道，咬下嘴唇之类的，这些可能是我们想到的一些传统的非语言兴趣表达方式。但根据我听到的以及我所做的工作，我认为每个人都可以接近任何人。但它始于连接点，然后让它从那里建立起来。
And it can build quickly. It's not like you have to stay in this neutral space of connection forever. But like to what you're saying, it's you never know where someone is at, what they're thinking about, how they're feeling on any given day. if they're up to receive a flirt. And so just working your way into it, I think, is a great, ultimately a great strategy, especially if this is someone you don't know. You're just out in public somewhere. You're at an event.
而且它可以快速建立。并不是说你必须永远停留在这种中立的连接空间里。但正如你所说，你永远不知道某人处于什么状态、在想什么、在任何特定日子的感觉如何。他们是否准备好接受调情。所以循序渐进，我认为最终是一个极好的策略，特别是如果这是一个你不认识的人。你只是在公共场合的某处。你在一个活动中。
And I really do see what you mean. It's like starting subtle also gives them time to reciprocate in a way. Yes, yes. What I mean? Especially like, okay, if you're listening to this episode and you like have someone in mind, you're like, okay, I want to start approaching this person. I am interested in them and I want them to know that I'm kind of open to it. Starting subtle and small, kind of test that and it tests that they're going, that it is a
我真的明白你的意思。从含蓄开始也给他们时间以某种方式做出回应。是的，是的。我是什么意思？特别是，好吧，如果你在听这集节目并且心里有某个人，你会想，好吧，我想开始接近这个人。我对他们感兴趣，我想让他们知道我是敞开接受的。从含蓄和微小开始，以此测试，测试他们是否也有同感，
mutual feeling rather than sometimes, you know, a more obvious come on where there is a lot more space to be rejected or maybe even embarrassed to go for it and to have them be like, no, I don't think of you that way. Maybe like that's another way of like. conceptualizing, flirting, it's like, it's like testing the waters a little bit before ultimately pursuing them. Have you found that to be like the case with people that you've spoken to or in your work? Oh yeah, absolutely. It's like, yeah, if you are looking to explore some more romantic interest, like if that is part of your intention with the flirt, it's like you've got
这是一种相互的感觉，而不是有时那种更明显的追求，因为那里的拒绝空间要大得多，甚至可能会感到尴尬，然后发现对方说：“不，我对你没有那种感觉。”也许这就是另一种概念化、调情的方式，就像是在最终追求他们之前稍微试探一下水温。你在与人交谈或在工作中发现情况是这样的吗？哦，绝对是的。就像，是的，如果你想探索更多浪漫的兴趣，如果那是你调情意图的一部分，就像你必须，
to, you've got to start somewhere. And it could be, you know, we're talking a lot of about in-person examples, but if it's online, if you're on the apps, if you're on social media, you want to slide into someone's DMs, it's like if you go in to the flirt right away with those expectations of I want this person to receive this flirt in this particular way, I want my interest to be reciprocated in this particular way. Well, ultimately, you're flirting with another person and there's no guarantee that that's going to happen. And so then maybe you are feeling rejected or you're feeling like you fumbled the flirt or like it just didn't go well um but it's like starting a little bit more subtly making that connection first expressing that interest having that interest received and
你必须从某个地方开始。这可能是，我们一直在谈论很多线下的例子，但如果是线上的，如果你在使用约会软件，如果你在社交媒体上，你想私信滑入别人的私信，如果你一上来就带着“我希望这个人以这种特定方式接受这个调情”、“我希望我的兴趣以这种特定方式得到回应”的期望去调情。好吧，归根结底，你是在和另一个人调情，并没有保证这一定会发生。所以也许你会感到被拒绝，或者觉得自己把调情搞砸了，或者进展不顺。但从更含蓄一点开始，首先建立连接，表达兴趣，让这种兴趣得到接受和
reciprocated and then you get the flirt back and like you can have a lot of fun in this initial phase it's not as if you're going up to someone and just like hello like it's like that's you know we're not just going with small talk, some back and forth banter here. The flirt is, it's really about energy. It's about vibrations as well. It's much, much more than just, you know, talking about the weather. I really, really like that. That's not flirting. Yeah. I also, I also feel like when I was flirting a lot more, like, romantically, it really was like, okay, it's not really about you. It's about the energy that I'm going to bring and hope, and like not even hoping, but knowing that what that is, that's going to be contagious. And also being like, okay, if I'm going to step into
回应，然后你就会得到调情的回馈，你可以在这个初始阶段玩得很开心。这不像你走到某人面前说“嗨”这么生硬，这不只是闲聊，这里有一些你来我往的玩笑。调情是，它真的关乎能量。它也关乎共鸣。它远不止是谈论天气。我真的很喜欢这样。那可不是调情。是的。我也觉得，当我以前更频繁地进行浪漫调情时，真的就像是，好吧，这其实不是关于你。而是关于我将要带来并希望、甚至不是希望而是确知这种能量会具有传染性。同时也觉得，好吧，如果我要介入
this situation, I talk about this a lot on the show of like the golden orb theory, which is my idea that if you visualize this like big golden orb, like coming out of you and encircling everyone around you with each breath, it's like propelling confidence, it's propelling all of this like good, vibrant energy and everyone that it touches will immediately like you. That's like the kind of energy that I really like to bring to the situations. And it was interesting because it's also a really great way of discerning, you know, whether people are actually kind of at your level in a sense, like whether they're going to be a good match.
这种情况，我在节目中经常谈到“金色宝珠理论”，这是我的一个想法，如果你想象这个巨大的金色宝珠从你身上散发出来，随着每一次呼吸，将周围的每个人都包裹其中，它就像是在推动自信，推动所有这些美好的、充满活力的能量，它所触及的每个人都会立刻喜欢你。这就是我真正喜欢带入这种情境的能量。这很有趣，因为这也是一个很好的方法去辨别，你知道，人们是否真的在你的水平上，从某种意义上说，他们是否会成为好伴侣。
Because if, you know, you've got someone who's like, you're putting out all this really great energy and they're just not really picking it up and reciprocating it or even just not even noticing it or even. and the worst case scenario, like, not enjoying it. It's kind of like, well, okay, this stopped me from going really, really slow and cautiously and, you know, only asking questions and trying to like toe the line between expressing romantic interest and six months later, realizing that this person is probably not for me versus kind of, again, putting it, like, putting it out there.
因为如果你遇到这样的人，你释放了所有这些非常棒的能量，而他们只是没有真正接住并回应，甚至没有注意到，或者最糟糕的情况，不喜欢它。这就好比，好吧，这阻止了我慢慢地、极其谨慎地前进，只问问题，试图在表达浪漫兴趣和六个月后意识到这个人可能不适合我之间走钢丝，相比之下，再次把这一切表达出来。
Yeah. And seeing what they take for themselves or what they kind of hand back to me. Do you have any other confidence tricks, like that kind of instance of like a hack to immediately like be in the mindset that is ready to embrace the flow or ready to float no matter the outcome? Do you have any like tricks for people to get into that state of mind where they're prepared and willing to give it a go? Yeah. I think I do and I hope I hope everyone listening will like this. As I know like oftentimes you you think about the flirt as your date. or you're in a relationship.
然后看看他们自己接受什么或者把什么回馈给我。你还有其他建立自信的技巧吗？比如那种瞬间进入准备好拥抱调情或无论结果如何都准备好调情的心态的绝招？你有什么可以让人们进入那种准备好并愿意尝试的状态的心态的诀窍吗？是的。我想我有，我希望每个听众都会喜欢这个。因为我知道通常你会把调情当作你的约会对象。或者你在恋爱中。
And so it oftentimes goes in the direction of romantic, of expressing romantic interest. And so like, let's just say you're out one night with friends, like you're dancing and you see someone that's super, right, you find really attractive. You may be seeing them around a few times and you want to go and approach them and flirt. But maybe like the last one didn't go well. You're fearful, you know, oh, they're already taken.
所以通常情况下，它会朝着浪漫的方向发展，表达出一种浪漫的兴趣。假设你某天晚上和朋友出去玩，比如在跳舞时看到一个你觉得超级有吸引力的人。你可能之前见过他们几次，想去和他们搭讪并调情。但也许上一次并不顺利，你心里会有所顾虑，觉得“哦，他们已经有对象了”。
They're actually here with someone and you didn't know. Or they are, right, their person isn't he. or they're going to reject you and then it can just like sour the rest of your night, you're feeling embarrassed and just like I've been in that situation plenty of times. And so
他们其实是和别人一起来的，而你并不知道。或者他们的那个人并不在场，再或者他们会拒绝你，这可能会让你的整个夜晚都变得索然无味，让你感到尴尬。我经历过很多次那种情况。所以，
one thing that I love to work with is thinking about the flirt as ultimately an act of service, going into it with no expectations, right? You're not going in there expressing romantic interest or intent right away, but just looking to
我非常喜欢做的一件事，就是把调情看作最终的一种服务行为，带着毫无期望的心态去进行。你不是一上去就表现出浪漫的兴趣或意图，而是为了
bring a smile to someone's face, to uplift your mood and their mood in the process, to have a laugh, to share a moment. And have it be that, have it be truly that in the present moment, and you will oftentimes be surprised what unfolds after that. I really like that. Again, back to those like lowering your expectations,
给某人的脸上带来微笑，在这个过程中提升你和对方的情绪，开怀大笑，分享一个美好的时刻。让它仅仅是那样，在当下真正成为那样，往往你会对之后发生的事情感到惊喜。我真的很喜欢这一点。再次回到那种降低期望值上来，
not of yourself, but of what someone else might be willing to give back, which is really good. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
不是对你自己的期望，而是对别人愿意给予回应的期望，这真的很棒。百分之二。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧的科学、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils
体能训练，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的方法。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油
were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
天生就具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方搜索TWO percent。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击了小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know.
乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在播客《Look Back at It》中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试着理清我们是如何在其中生存下来的。其中包括最近的一集，马麦特·希尔大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊快克，只是想让大家知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。我开始看出这其中有一条主线了。我们现在还把艾滋病也摆上台面了。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我不认为有什么年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness, month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多出色嘉宾的对话。
with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear him. earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，太沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得做一个好人在尘世间很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
这也是两个不同的信任层次。我希望你能够真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索Learn the Hard Way并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in silence, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
随后的法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的证明真相的法庭之战的序幕。你悄悄地篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我篡改测试了一次。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So I want to talk about something else here because I think we're talking about flirting a lot in the sense of like casual connections, people you've just met, strangers even. How can we incorporate flirting into like long-term relationships? Because it's kind of like it can't just be something that you only pull out when you want to get someone. And then as soon as you've got them, you, you know, you stop the show. How do you kind of keep that as part of a healthy relationship? It's a good question because I I've like I've said that the flirt is the one thing that you'll have from your first meeting even before the first meeting all the way through the relationship like this is the one continuous thread that is going to like the first date starts with the flirt the second date you get there through the flirt and so on and so on and should it blossom into relationship the flirt is what is in many ways carrying like it's
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。所以我想在这里谈谈别的事情，因为我认为我们讨论了很多关于调情的话题，比如随意的连结、刚刚认识的人、甚至是陌生人。我们如何将调情融入长期关系中呢？因为这有点像，它不能只成为你想要追求某人时才拿出来的东西。一旦你得到了他们，你，你知道的，就把戏码收起来了。你如何把这一点作为保持健康关系的一部分呢？这是一个好问题，因为我曾经说过，调情是你从第一次见面甚至在第一次见面之前一直延续到整个关系中的唯一东西，这是唯一一条连续不断的线索，第一场约会从调情开始，第二场约会通过调情推进，以此类推，如果它发展成恋爱关系，调情在许多方面承载着……
It's a part of it. It's a part of it for sure. And being that the flirt is all about connection. So ultimately, how do you all like to connect? Like, what is something that you both enjoy that is super fun to do? If it's a poly or open relationship, that can be part of this discussion too. And so it's ultimately doing things that make you feel really connected to one another. And so sometimes I'll work with couples or one part of the couple where they're feeling disconnected.
这是其中的一部分。这绝对是其中的一部分。既然调情的核心就是连结。那么归根结底，你们都喜欢如何连结呢？比如，你们俩都喜欢什么超级有趣的事情？如果是多元之爱或开放式关系，也可以成为讨论的一部分。所以最终要做的就是做那些让你们觉得彼此紧密相连的事情。因此，有时我会与伴侣双方或其中一方合作，当他们感到彼此疏远时。
and it's because they're not having a lot of quality time. It's maybe they don't feel considered when they're communicating, right? It's sort of like, oh, yeah, sure, sort of very being brushed off. So if you're not feeling truly seen in your relationship, of course, the flirt, it's like, that's going to go out the door. So there are some foundational things to work on perhaps around communication, around just understanding one another, respecting boundaries needs, like, some of that. But flirting can also be a huge part of what is going to have a relationship, be healthy,
那是因为他们没有很多共度高质量时光的机会。也许他们在沟通时觉得没有被体谅，对吧？有点像是，哦，行吧，行吧，感觉被敷衍了。所以如果你在恋爱中没有真正被看见，当然，调情就会被抛到九霄云外。因此，也许有一些基础工作需要去做，比如围绕沟通、围绕相互理解、尊重界限和需求等。但调情也可以是让关系保持健康、
and remain healthy as it's a way to connect to one another. And so I oftentimes like to share this one example. This is from my mom and stepdad. And what they do is they got this pack of action figures that's these little figurines, I think, from the dollar store. here in the States. And they hide them all over the house. And maybe on these action figures, like there's these little notes or maybe like the action figure is like holding something random like a flower from outside. Or maybe it has this little note that says, I love you. Or something
并保持健康状态的重要组成部分，因为它是彼此连结的一种方式。所以我经常喜欢分享这样一个例子。这是我妈妈和继父的故事。他们做的是，他们买了一包动作玩偶，也就是这些小雕像，我想是在美国这里的杂货店买的。他们把这些玩偶藏在屋里的各个地方。也许这些玩偶身上还带着这些小纸条，或者也许这个玩偶手里拿着什么随机的东西，比如外面的一朵花。或者也许它有一张小纸条上面写着，我爱你。或者类似
like that. Not a ton of time that really went into creating this moment of connection. And so I think just exploring, you know, maybe that was an example that you really like. If you're out there listening in a relationship, I think it's bringing those really genuine moments of connection into the relationship where the whole point is just to say, I see you, I'm glad you're in my life, I love you. And that's, the flirt can serve you there. Yeah. I really like that idea. That's actually very, very sweet. It's so cute. It's so cute. And it's almost like, um, maybe part of being flirty is being childish a little bit and really tapping into that part of you that's going to be willing to not be serious all the time as adult life kind of
这样的话。并没有花大量的时间来真正创造这个连结的时刻。所以我觉得只要去探索，你知道的，也许那是一个你真的很喜欢的例子。如果你作为一个处在恋爱关系中的听众听到这里，我觉得这就是把那些真正真挚的连结时刻带入到关系中，其全部意义就只是为了说，我看到你了，我很高兴你出现在我的生命里，我爱你。就是这样，调情可以在这里帮到你。是的。我真的很喜欢这个主意。这其实非常非常甜蜜。太可爱了。太可爱了。而且这有点像，嗯，也许调情的一部分就是稍微带点孩子气，真正去触碰你内心深处的那一部分，让你愿意不必总是那么严肃，就像成年人的生活
makes us serious and it makes us think about big questions and responsibilities and all these things and it's like actually no get back to like the real innocent oh my god gentle gooey part of your relationship and tap into that and it's so cute because um my grandparents who are you know my grandpa is about to turn 90 and he is so flirtatious with my grandma still and I'm sure like that part of their relationship like the more sexual side of their relationship like has probably died down a little bit but you wouldn't be able to tell because it's like yeah he's always like you know has these gorgeous pet names for her it's like spoiling her and it's kind of like okay I can see that this is actually a deliberate strategy that you are using not to keep the love alive but to keep this
让我们变得严肃，让我们思考宏大的问题和责任以及所有这些事情，而实际上不，回到那种真正纯真的、哦天哪、温柔黏人的关系部分去，去触碰它，这太可爱了，因为，嗯，我的祖父母，你知道的，我爷爷快90岁了，他对我奶奶依然非常调情，我敢肯定，他们关系中的那一部分，比如他们关系中比较有性吸引力的一面，可能已经稍微消退了一点，但你绝对看不出来，因为，是的，他总是，你知道的，会给她起这些华丽的昵称，就像是在宠溺她一样。这有点像，好吧，我能看出这其实是一个深思熟虑的策略，你用它不是为了维持爱，而是为了保持这种
like spark a flame rather than just something that dwindles. So do you see that a lot with couples where it's like, what you're really missing here is just finding ways to connect and appreciate each other through the flirt? It's, yeah, because like as sometimes a relationship can become really transactional. It's like it's just about doing things for one another. If like you're both super busy, you're building careers, you're raising a family, perhaps. It's just, okay, I'm doing this. this. It just becomes, you're playing your roles that serves a purpose to an extent and this relationship becomes very transactional. Well, then it's like you're two people kind of cohabitating perhaps and it's like, where's the flirt? Where's the romance? And I feel like that's just as
火花燃烧，而不是让它逐渐熄灭。所以你经常在伴侣身上看到这种情况吗，就是那种，你们真正缺少的是通过调情来寻找连结和欣赏彼此的方式？是的，因为有时候一段关系会变得非常功利。这就好像这只是为了互相为对方做事情。如果你们两个都超级忙，在建立事业，也许还要抚养家庭。这只是，好吧，我在做这个，我在做那个。这只是变成了，你在扮演你的角色，在某种程度上达到了目的，而这段关系变得非常功利。嗯，那就像是两个人可能只是在同居，然后就像是，调情在哪里？浪漫在哪里？我觉得这同样是
valuable as all the other things that you would do for someone. Like I think sometimes the bare bones of a relationship are not enough. Showing up for them is great and like doing the dishes is great. And saying, I love you is great. And saying, I love you is great. but even having quality to bear minimum it's like and sometimes like I was talking to someone about this the other day and she's like yeah you know when your partner says I love you but like you know they don't actually like love you in that moment they're just saying it because they know that they are that they love you in general and it's really like taking the time to be like no like this is a conscious decision of mine to be like actively present in this relationship and to again
和为你做的所有其他事情一样有价值。我觉得有时候一段关系的基础是不够的。为他们出现很好，洗碗也很好。说我爱你很好。说我爱你很好。但哪怕只是勉强维持，就像有时候，前几天我和某人谈起这个，她说，是的你知道的，当你的伴侣说我爱你，但你知道他们在那一刻其实并不是真的爱你，他们说这话只是因为他们知道他们在总体上是爱你的，而这真的需要花时间去想：不，这是一个有意识的决定，我要积极地参与到这段关系中，再次
something you said earlier like to use this as a service like this is a service like this is a to you to keep this relationship alive. So my final question is any final tips, tricks, practical advice, pick up lines, anything that comes to mind that you think can elevate the flirt for people. I mean, this could be a whole other episode. Yeah. Just on this one question, I mean, I think, like, hopefully it's come through in the interview today that I am very playful and I love to have a lot of fun. So I think just coming back to the part of
就像你刚才说的，把它当作一种服务，就像这是一项服务，这是为了让这段关系保持活力。所以我的最后一个问题是，有没有什么最后的技巧、诀窍、实用的建议、搭讪台词，或者任何想到的能帮大家提升调情水平的东西？我的意思是，这完全可以成为另一期节目。是的。仅就这一个问题而言，我的意思是，我希望今天的采访能体现出这一点，我是非常爱玩的，我喜欢有很多乐趣。所以我觉得回到
the episode about your flirt style, maybe you really relate or identify with one of them. I think reflecting back to parts of this episode where we talked about what the flirt is, that it's about connection, that it comes without those expectations in the present moment. So having some of that flirt framework in place. And then when it comes to flirting in real life, it's like, you know, Like, have those one or two ways that you like to introduce yourself, that you like to start, initiate the flirt. It can be with some eye contact, smiling, that kind of thing. So just to give you, like, as an example, say, like, I were at the club, the club, and I saw someone cute. I wanted to flirt with.
本期关于你的调情风格的部分，也许你真的能感同身受或认同其中一种。我想回顾一下本期节目的部分内容，我们讨论了什么是调情，它是关于连接的，它是在当下不带任何期望的。所以在脑海中保留一些这样的调情框架。然后当涉及到现实生活中的调情时，就像，你知道，有那一两种你喜欢介绍自己的方式，你喜欢开始、发起调情的方式。可以通过一些眼神交流、微笑之类的。所以举个例子，假设，我在酒吧，夜店，我看到一个可爱的人。我想去调情。
And so instead of just like going right up, tapping them on the shoulder, like, hey, can I buy you a drink or something like that, I might, you know, kind of make eye. contact with them at some point, like around the bar on the dance floor, come over to them, be like, hey, I saw you looking at me from across the way and then make a joke about, oh, my God, do I still have my name tag on or oh, is my tag on inside out? Is my shirt on inside out or something like that? And then bring some humor into it, hopefully have them smile, laugh, and then at that point introduce myself, hey, my name is Benjamin. Yeah.
所以不是直接走过去，拍拍他们的肩膀，比如，嘿，能请你喝一杯吗之类的，我可能会，你知道的，在某个时刻和他们有眼神交流，比如在吧台周围或舞池里，然后走过去，对他们说，嘿，我看到你从那边看着我，然后开个玩笑，天哪，我还带着名牌吗，或者，哦，我的标签翻里朝外了吗？我的衬衫穿反了吗之类的话。然后把一些幽默感带进去，希望让他们微笑、大笑，然后在那时介绍我自己，嘿，我叫本杰明。是的。
What's your night going? Yeah, and I really, really like that. You're in the flirt at that point. Introducing yourself can be a part of it. And then detaching from any and all expectations. At that point, maybe that's all, maybe that's the whole flirt. Or maybe we go to the dance floor. Maybe we go outside and talk more.
你今晚过得怎么样？是的，我真的很喜欢这样。你在那个时候就已经在调情了。介绍自己可以是一部分。然后抛开任何和所有的期望。在那一点上，也许这就够了，也许这就是全部的调情。或者我们可以去舞池。或者我们可以去外面多聊聊。
Yeah. Who knows? Yeah. I really like that. Who knows? And also that, sorry, I'm already, I'm continuing this conversation of it, even though I was like last piece. Last piece of advice, but I will say, like, one thing that you just mentioned there was, like, the self-deprecating humor as well. Like, if you want to take,
是的。谁知道呢？是的。我真的很喜欢这样。谁知道呢？还有，抱歉，我已经开始了，我正在继续这个对话，尽管我刚才说这是最后一部分。最后的建议，但我要说的是，你刚才提到的其中一点，也是关于自嘲式的幽默。如果你想带走，
if you want to take the pressure off, maybe, you know, just make fun of yourself. Bring a little bit of, like, lightness and, like, yeah, just lightness to the situation so that neither of you feel like, okay, wait, there's expectations here. If this person isn't interested, like, they need to immediately shut me down or I need to be immediately conscious of them not liking it. Like, it's, Like it's, it's okay to just be a little bit again. I think this is a repetitive thing I've been saying. And that you've been saying is like, just be playful with it. It's a big part of it.
如果你想减轻压力，也许，你知道的，只是取笑你自己。给这种情况带来一点轻松感，和，是的，一点轻松感，这样你们两个都不会觉得，好吧，等等，这里有期望。如果这个人不感兴趣，他们需要立刻拒绝我，或者我需要立刻意识到他们不喜欢。就像，这，就像这是，可以只是稍微地，再次。我觉得这是一个我一直在说的重复的事情。而你一直在说的是，就是顺其自然地玩。这是很大的一部分。
And the flirt is so much it's about possibility. It's about opportunity. And so if you find you're putting a lot of pressure on yourself to flirt, like even I, I'm not in a flirting mood all the time. I don't flirt with literally everybody. So if you're not feeling up to it or you feel like, or someone you think they were flirting with you and you didn't pick up on it or someone you wanted to flirt with. And now that say you're at the club and that time has passed, oh my God, I'll never see them again. There's always another flirt. You didn't mess it up. It's okay. So just take the pressure off yourself where sometimes I feel like we we feel like we have to perform in the flirt where we have to show up as a certain person where, oh, now I want this person to see me as sexy or flirty or fun or. whatever. Like what you're, because you did an episode on this somewhat recently about this idea of perception and how
调情很大程度上是关于可能性的。它是关于机会的。所以如果你发现自己给自己施加了很大的压力去调情，就像甚至我，我也不是随时随地都想调情。我并不是和字面上的每个人调情。所以如果你觉得状态不对，或者你觉得，或者有人你觉得他们在对你调情而你没有注意到，或者你想和谁调情。而现在假设你在夜店，那个时间已经过去了，天哪，我再也见不到他们了。总会有下一次调情。你没有搞砸。没关系。所以只要卸下自己的压力，有时我觉得我们觉得自己必须在调情中表现，必须以某种特定的人的形象出现，哦，现在我想让这个人把我视为性感、调情、有趣或别的什么。就像你正在做的那样，因为你最近做了一期关于这种感知概念以及
we're perceived. And I think this is, this happens in the flirt too where sometimes we show up as the way we want to be perceived versus showing up as truly ourselves. And this is back to the point of connection with the self. It's like, yeah, I want you to just show up as you, whoever that is, whoever you are, wherever you are, just to be you. Yeah. It's one of the hardest things in the world, though.
我们是如何被感知的节目。我想这也发生在调情中，有时我们表现出我们希望被感知的方式，而不是表现出真正的自己。这又回到了与自我建立连接的这一点上。就像，是的，我希望你表现出真正的自己，无论那是谁，无论你是谁，无论你在哪里，只要做你自己就好。是的。但这确实是世界上最难的事情之一。
Yeah, I know. I know. I love my way. We're like, just be yourself. But it's like, no, it takes so well. But this is part of it. Yeah. Yeah.
是的，我知道。我知道。我喜欢我的方式。我们总是说，做你自己。但事实上，这需要很好的功底。但这也是其中的一部分。是的。是的。
This is part of it. Yeah. This is part of it. Yeah. I'm open to whatever happens. Like we talk about in the fear of being perceived episode. It's like that you need to, sometimes the best way to get over your fear of rejection is, is through exposure.
这也是其中的一部分。是的。这也是其中的一部分。是的。我对任何可能发生的事情都持开放态度。就像我们在害怕被感知那期节目里谈到的那样。就像你需要，有时候克服恐惧被拒绝的最好方法是通过暴露疗法。
And just being like, okay, they might not be reciprocate. might not reciprocate and they'll still be okay. So I feel like that is a great place to end it. I want to say thank you so much for coming on for this episode. Where can everyone find you? Oh my goodness. I would love for everyone to come flirt with me on flirt Instagram, which is Instagram, flirt talk, which is TikTok. There's flirt to YouTube. I'm very much about branding and my podcast, flirtations, new episodes dropping every week where I talk about flirting, yes, but also lots of dating advice as well. I really focus on in my work the flirt through defining that relationship. So this early phase of dating where it's like sometimes what's happening?
然后就是想，好吧，他们可能不会回应。可能不会回应，但他们仍然会好好的。所以我觉得这是一个很好的结束方式。非常感谢你来参加这一期节目。大家可以在哪里找到你？哦，天哪。我很希望大家来我的Instagram上和我调情，也就是Instagram的flirt talk，也就是TikTok。还有flirt的YouTube。我非常注重品牌建设，还有我的播客flations，每周都有新节目上线，我在那里谈论调情，是的，但也分享很多约会建议。我的工作真正集中在通过界定关系来寻找调情。所以在约会的早期阶段，有时候到底发生了什么？
Yeah, I know. It's always up in the year. But that actually, I feel like if you're like going through a single period at the moment, a low confidence period, definitely check out and stuff. It's incredible. It's amazing. And as always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to give us a follow, leave a five-star review. Whatever you are listening right now, maybe share with a friend who needs a little bit of flight advice or, you know, needs to be on floodstagram, whatever it is. And make sure you go and check out all of Ben's work. Until next week, stay safe, stay kind, and be gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
是的，我知道。总是悬而未决。但实际上，我觉得如果你现在正经历单身期，自信心低谷期，一定要去看看这些东西。太不可思议了。太棒了。和往常一样，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时关注我们，留下五星好评。无论你在哪里收听，也许可以分享给需要一点飞行建议的朋友，或者，你知道的，需要去flirtstagram的朋友，无论是什么。一定要去看看本的所有作品。直到下周，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's TWA% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a Podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》，即IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA%。回顾一个播客。来自1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。
84 is big to me I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick a year unpack what went down And try to make sense Of how we survived it
84对我来说意义重大，我是萨姆·杰伊，我是亚历克斯·英格利士，每一集我们都会选择一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段时光的
With our friends Fellow comedians And favorite offers Like Mark Lamont Hill On the 80s It was a wild year I don't think There's a more important
和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的创作者，比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔，谈论80年代，那是一个疯狂的年份，我不认为有什么更重要的
year for black people Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio App Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts Hey what's good y'all You're listening
对黑人来说的年份，在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看》嘿，大家好，你们正在收听的是
And learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
和你的专属治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯一起艰难地吸取教训。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不安全的诚实对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要，
listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听艰难吸取教训。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg, a lesbian. Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·兰奇尼。我的脑子炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是陷入爱河。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听陷入爱河播客。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个IHeart播客。保证是真人。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。